hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play Fran bow Fran
bow I'm not quite sure but this is
actually a pretty interesting horror
game that we've that's different from
what we've seen so far because it's like
a point-and-click adventure style game
from what I've seen from the previews
but I don't know a lot about the game
other than that it's supposedly very
creepy it comes at the recommendation of
both you guys and other youtubers so
hello hi there little girl I see my
parents they look happy I know I'm not a
little girl voice but just pretend they
have a present for me I wonder it's a
cat so sweet and pretty dark is the
deepest night darkest the empty bits of
your eyes it's mister midnight my best
friend
my only friend we are having dinner and
I see Aunt Grace - I really like her a
lot
it's Friday my parents are going out
aunt grace takes good care of me
we are having so much fun it's Monday
night
I'm playing with mr. midnight but
something feels real bad hello hi a
strange creature outside my window I
don't like it
it scares me excuse me - suddenly I hear
something
it's mom screaming I want to know what's
wrong maybe it was that thing is outside
the window a heavy light shines from my
parents room I go closer and closer and
closer mom dad please don't whoa
mommy daddy oh my gosh that is some
messed up Wow
holy crap geez the house is spitting
blood oh thank you mr. midnight please
protect me hey no no scare away the
monster oh okay that's not a motto it's
some cultists without explain the symbol
on the ground Fran please follow my
voice to the count of three you will
wake up one two okay whoa all right yeah
three hello my dumb friend how do you
feel I feel like dying don't understand
why you make me do this try to calm down
this is part of your recovery my parents
are dead
oh poor thing everything will get better
I promise will it's better than let me
go just let me go that would be better
you should not tell me how to do my job
little girl but now I got something for
you friend
oh really see the desk there's a little
package for you it's from Aunt Grace
take it
alrighty then it's a purse open it
there's something inside what is this
examine here is the purse you like so
much I thought you would appreciate it I
was thinking of you that you like to
examine objects and combine them with
other things give it a good use never
forget the creativity is the most
greatest gift you have love Aunt Grace
she is worried about you Fran I'm
worried too because I'm not mad and
still here shut up wide Godley stop it
you're out of control young lady I'm so
tired of all of this I just want to go
to my room yes you can leave but before
you do it's time for your new medicine
no more medicine I don't want to try new
medicine it's called - Oh teen it will
make you feel very relaxed nurse ah shut
up nurse Hey anything new today doctor
Dhin Dhin nothing actually same visions
as before oh I see here Fran take your
medicine no no I refuse we're gonna
punch you in the face what's this on
that I'm blinking rapidly all right I'll
take it
fine whatever yeah
I don't feel good
whoa what the hell Oh exploded into meat
Oh No
take her back to a room that's not good
oh and nurse don't let her take this
ever again
everything's gone pastel Oh Oh I again
beware Fran bow if you leave the house
of madness I will hunt you catch you and
bring you back to insanity
okey-dokey Fran wake up it's my friend
mr. midnight the medicine will help you
escape I don't know about that I'll be
waiting for you in the forest something
tells me that kitty cat isn't good I
love you or her parents really dead I'm
not entirely sure now chapter one sober
day I'm still here hideous place I have
to get out of here all right whoa what's
with the eyeballs I guess that's the
turning mechanic okay oh sweet sweet
melody
you're awfully melodramatic for a little
girl see I should get the key for this
all right let's see what's out the
window uh-oh holy moly something fell a
handy hook I'll save it to play pirate
later golden hook that fell with the
curtains and see
see I don't have anything to combine it
with just yet one more time lalala one
more time oh okay see Fran bow age 10
sex female the patient was found near
Oswald Asylum showing signs of
hallucination and depression the patient
is receiving treatment from dr. Darin we
have tried different medication and all
has been cancelled because of side
effects hopefully this won't fall on my
head while I'm sleeping no sleep bed and
tiny are you are hiding from me letters
letters letters numbers I hate the
monster with the mask I have to find mr.
midnight I have to find him now I miss
my kitty he hides because he is afraid
he told me that the medicine would show
me where he is I thought that was a poem
at first I I read that we just woke up
I'm not that floppy
we'll just flop it in what do you mean
floppy you gonna look out the window I
can't fix that okay well this is
disconcerting my legs are just fine what
if we got here hide well let's try the
letters of the alphabet abcdefg 7a hey
hi9 1 2 3 4 sorry I'm horribly stupid
did that do it oh come on I thought for
sure we a b c d e f g h is 8 sorry there
we go
see i'm terribly stupid haha sorry i'm
horrific ly stupid ah okay that was a
mistake
Wow alrighty then hello miss miss
looks like you shut up pretty good ha ok
let's combine this and this maybe the
color won't stay on combined with what
ok so that's that's not good watch your
steps Oh wouldn't miss your horse are
you having a good time a better time
than I'm having right now I'll that's
for sure
well there's only this wait hang on
maybe if I take a pillow
oh man that is disturbing holy crap
one Pleasant nightmares oh are you
sleeping sweet bunny I don't think so
maybe I could use this on okay didn't
work use this on this I have no guilt I
have no guilt I have no guilt I have no
oh boy hello a little kid hello boy how
are you doing hello no way out there are
many ways out everything's locked indeed
but everything will open from the office
how do I get there he doesn't want me to
tell you who him who is him oh is it
someone on the chair little kid oh hi
how's it gone there buddy all doors are
closed you are a prisoner of my games
okay and nobody will help you escape
leave me alone I hate you mommy and
daddy I need you so much right now no I
won't let that monster stop me I can't
play with you now I'm on a very secret
mission Phil Brian stoned okay what's in
the ear under the bed ooh a secret box
to combine with that the hook and the
nonsense combined with that it just
won't work out wooden box it's open
ah there's a key suddenly lose all right
good good good good good let's uh take a
pill here see what's gonna happen
see uh oh my god that doesn't get any
better
hello mister dear Oh your head I'll try
to put your head back on oh my goodness
the key to happiness hi how's it going a
little kid I can't seem to go near you
oh you are one messed up little girl I
will give you that let's try the key on
this there we go
got it there's something inside what do
we have we have a photo of my family and
this is my aunt I'm guessing I'll guard
you with my life what is this can I
combine this with something okay
combined with that what did we get ah
special key cool maybe I can use this to
pick the lock on this door here use on
the door use on the door come on yeah to
happiness
I guess ah don't mind me buddy just
gonna go into my little world here you
don't see me do you Wow guess I could
reach it but my arms are too short let's
try the hook ah come on but you can I
believe in you we tried to leave oh
goody
the trone is empty I didn't realize that
anyone could see me pooping gross I can
and will hold it the King likes drawings
I don't like this I wonder how it feels
when you die pretty sad thoughts for a
little girl
I will admit alright hello mr. security
guard hello sir can I ask you something
of course little girl what's on your
mind open the door for me please why is
that my cat's outside please sorry girl
even if I wanted to open I can
who can't open it then some people but
there's a code and that's almost
impossible to find who is the code I
won't tell you
now leave I'm reading here all right
five men go into the kitchen hello nurse
Lee you're not shut up just bad hello
Fran are you to me I see dead animals
just tell the truth just telling it like
it is you mean on the television no for
real just forget it
very well Fran crazy psycho okay got a
pink rope yeah
pink rope don't know what that's gonna
do for me hello girl I can give you the
magical stash Shh what magical style the
magical stuff that will make everything
fall asleep Oh
everything what do you mean here is a
gift just taken that looks like a
different type of bill what is it
thank you what is it the magic of stuff
to sleep shut up okay on the flowers the
painting mom used to pain roses I can't
sit the sofas jaqen wonder what's inside
the bottle nothing really interesting
I'm gonna say good good good
oh oh that's why the couch was taken
okay you look petrified and the nurse is
dead and she has something in her hand
let's see oh no not you sorry c'mon or
examined Blanca if you need to go out
turn off the alarm the door open set the
clock on the right time into the code on
the computer three six four two three
six four two hello little kids Betty
Betty I like you this game is messed up
alright don't love me I'm eating donut
my sward I didn't know was yours
sorry
is it bounce be clearly to me I am your
king the King likes drawings I'm out to
you there very well my child what is the
purpose of your visit
I want JIP walking cane I could use that
to get the key do you mean my sward yes
your highness your swad what would you
give me in exchange you like drawings
anything you need your highness
bring me a castle and a horse and you'll
get much bored
hello kid I don't know where to look
sometimes closed door can give you more
than an open one what does that mean
you're crazy kid
time to go psycho oh they are dead they
certainly seem dead okay are you choking
do better next time
good good glad you're taking this psycho
world so well little girl okay alright
let's go outside cuz obviously there's
nothing good for me here man I swear
this is so messed up oh my god okay so I
need to find something that I can get
for the girl maybe I can do a drawing
combined with that there we go
that that is exactly what I had in mind
alright I'm doing great in this one I
mean everything in here is messed up but
uh at least I'm doing good now you go
little kid ya pee now could I have your
sward oh that's beautiful exactly what I
dreamt of you can take my sward now it's
yours thank you good sir
no can I combine anything in here okay
they're pretty prettier walking cane
there we go
the grab o matic mm see pills it just
won't work what is this magical dust to
make everything fall asleep use with
the food no hang on see where you took
something oh okay nevermind use with
okay you take this pill nobody should
know that I have this okay anyway let's
go into the psycho world and then get
this key off the wreck no not my cane no
I'm really give it back to me hey that's
my grub o matic you crazy
No what of it
I'll take it back gah come on oh I'm
gonna make you fun oh I know what I'm
gonna do ahaha ahaha
here have some of this yeah I got a
probably gotta go back into the normal
world or you want a bagel I'm so yeah
make a bagel here hope we can be friends
I'm sorry
oh what's that it's cake are you blind
I thought you would like it oh that's
very kind of you thank you I wonder what
happened now are you dead
no you're just asleep no I thought I
thought something weird would have
happened okay so I got the grab o matic
let's see come back to your Great
Creator now I can get this key off the
rack I swear that I could reach that but
whatever whatever let's go in the office
we're doing good so far I love to open
mail but this is not for me flowers
bloom eyes blue dr. den this is where I
was in the beginning 3 6 4 2
I apologize I still have this cough it's
been way too long said Clark on time
pending what does that mean oh I need to
set the clock to what three six what is
the right time good question something I
need not really boring medical papers
doctor used to sit here huh and go to
the second world Wow
there's the King's horse I swear every
time I go beware of the time what is the
name of your cat mr. midnight how genius
wait no hang on I got it maybe I got it
do I cycle around okay hang on let's go
backwards there we go come on come there
we go mr. midnight close that 364 to I
believe was a code I may be mistaken but
it's in my inventory if it's not done
alarm active password to deactivate
armed three six whoa what the Wow okay
that's okay hang on no that's what okay
hey on the way to no hang on well I got
this for - no for - God dang it
gosh dang it ah ah oh this is gonna be
hard no it's not for so that goes up to
six and when that goes up to zero there
we go okay three and then sorry of my
brain I'm too stupid go got it
yeah nailed it I'm so smart I guess I
could have done the right one first and
then oh yes I am the best let's get out
of here let's go home yeah let's go yeah
all right cool beans that was as I
didn't mention it before but this was
just the demo a very early version of
game but that was so cool I love
the kind of to world dynamic of it the
one really freaky insane world and the
point-and-click admit I haven't played a
good point and click adventure in a long
time that was really cool I like that a
ton they didn't have cheap jump scares I
mean you knew what was happening when
you took that bill and went into the
other world that was awesome so please
the demo is free play it for yourself
maybe there's something I overlooked but
check out the IndieGoGo they're trying
to get this game funded it's a great
game I highly recommend it
it was awesome like it was amazing I
really loved the art style in the
direction had this disturbing feel the
whole time I can't wait for the full
game so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
but
but God
hahahahahaha